un avenir qui semble donc prometteur
pour les découvertes scientifiques
mais frédéric la nasa qui donc
l'administration nationale de
l'aéronautique et de l'espace n'est plus
tout à fait ce qu'elle était du temps de
la grande conquête spatiale en effet
céline en fait la nasa a connu un peu
des hauts des bas au fur et à mesure des
succès puis des échecs bon évidemment
les succès on ne reconnaît quelques-uns
quand même une une photo là vraiment qui
est légendaire en 1969 apollo 11
évidemment marche sur la lune ou encore
bien sûr les fameuses navettes ont
permis de faire des bonds technologiques
en avant jusqu'au moment où après avoir
perdu 2 on a décidé vraiment de mettre
le clou dans le cercueil du programme en
cela étant dit c'est sûr que le budget
de la nasa a beaucoup évolué au gré du
temps aussi regarder en pleine guerre
froide en pleine course à l'exploration
spatiale en avait ça représentait 4 4 %
du budget total des états unis c'était
vraiment énorme
mais regardez à partir de 81 ans dont on
est descendu à 1 % pour finalement au
joli se retrouvaient à 0.5 pour cent
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire un
chiffre est bien la nasa aujourd'hui son
budget de fonctionnement représentent
quand même 17 milliards de dollars et sa
emploie quand même dix sept mille cinq
cents personnes donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important il on voit que
ce n'est plus que ça a été moins de
moyens financiers plus de navettes
n'empêche que la nasa continue de faire
des découvertes qui sont intéressants
intéressante
évidemment découvert technologique
extraordinaire au même niveau de la
santé aussi un toutes les données qui
ont été ramassés notamment par chris
hadfield lors de son séjour dans la
station spatiale internationale pendant
six mois si tout des données qui
permettent vraiment à d'avancé au niveau
du progrès technologique
c'est sûr que bon on a encore cette
année on a découvert vous savez cette
petite planète cette exoplanète là la
petite cousine éloignée de la terre dont
kepler 452 b il y avait également tout
l'exploration sur mars avec notamment
les équipements comme blogger ou claudia
rossetti et puis bien sûr là ça c'est un
petit peu le joyau de la couronne de la
nasa mais également de tous les
investissements internationaux c'est la
fameuse station spatiale internationale
et puis aussi bombay ya le fameux
télescope un bol c'est important parce
que ça permet depuis 25 ans maintenant
de récolter énormément de photos et de
données sur un peu d'où vient notre
univers
évidemment il ya des photos
extraordinaires de galaxies comme celle
là ou encore par exemple de ces
nébuleuses regarder gonfler vos yeux de
cette merveille extraordinaire quand
même qui nous vient de l'espace donc
encore cette fameuse début deux brefs
on le voit il ya quand même des avancées
importantes grâce à la nasa est bon mais
la prochaine étape ce sera probablement
d'aller découvrir une vie extraterrestre
on sera probablement pas les petits
bonshommes verts comme comme on oublie
souvent may énormément chose qu'on a
appris notamment la fin de l'univers
c'est dans 24 milliards d'années donc ça
fait beaucoup télé journaux ni vous ni
moi ni seront d'ailleurs merci beaucoup
fait rire
non